Towards the beginning
of this lecture,
we stated that the
goal of a baseball team
is to make the playoffs and
we built predictive models
to achieve this goal.
But why isn't the goal
of a baseball team
to win the playoffs or
win the World Series?
Billy Beane and Paul
Depodesta see their job
as making sure the team
makes it to the playoffs,
and after that,
all bets are off.
The A's made it to the playoffs
four years in a row-- 2000,
2001, 2002, and 2003-- but they
didn't win the World Series.
Why not?
In Moneyball, they say that
"over a long season luck
evens out, and skill
shines through.
But in a series of
three out of five,
or even four out of seven,
anything can happen."
In other words, the playoffs
suffer from the sample size
problem.
There are not enough games to
make any statistical claims.
Let's see if we can verify
this using our data set.
The number of teams
in the playoffs
has changed over the years.
So let's only use the
years with eight teams
in the playoffs, which was the
number of teams in the playoffs
in 2002, the year
Moneyball discusses.
We can compute the correlation
between whether or not
the team wins the World
Series-- a binary variable--
and the number of
regular season wins,
since we would expect
teams with more wins
to be more likely to
win the World Series.
This correlation is
0.03, which is very low.
So it turns out that winning
regular season games gets you
to the playoffs, but in
the playoffs, there too
few games for luck to even out.
Next week, we'll discuss
logistic regression,
which we'll be able to use
to predict whether or not
the team will win
the World Series.